hi Sarah you're muted by the way there
you go Hi how are you good so you have a
disagreement with me tonight is that did
I read that right
um
yeah I guess so
um I was just kind of told to come on
and talk to you if that's okay yeah okay
fire away what do you got for me
[Music]
some of your stuff that I've seen
I've seen women being attracted to men
who have money
and that like men like women for sex and
women like men for money and it's kind
of stated as a fact well it's it's men
or success objects to women and women
are Beauty objects to men
right so it's just several things you've
said that um you know you're you blow up
on the Internet I've seen some of your
videos you know I've watched them and
passing and um
just respectfully I just wanted to say
that I do disagree and
um yeah you don't see Menace uh success
objects
no okay how do you view man
as people okay yeah like I have a
younger brother
um he's an incredibly talented very
emotionally intelligent guy and you know
he had a choice in college he went to a
really great University he had a choice
you know go into computer engineering
work at Google make a lot of money or
become a psychotherapist you know and he
chose he chose the money route okay and
he's not happy now he's burnt out he's
working this crazy job and I'm like you
know you would make a great therapist
like I think you could help people like
why did you go this other route you're
so talented and I think people have
talents and intellects and it's not just
about this very like binary thing you're
discussing you know what I mean well
money is just one piece of the puzzle
when it comes to success right right
like a
a success object to women is what they
what they look at when they put all the
pieces of the puzzle together right he's
competent he's funny he can make it rain
meaning he knows how to make money and
whether you can make you know a million
dollars a year or a hundred thousand
dollars a year is still making money
it's just it's just the level of which
wealth comes in
um can you fix things is he humble does
he know how to make me laugh like uh
like the success component is probably
the biggest part especially how old are
you Sarah
um I'm 29. okay especially as you get
older because women you know we're here
for a reason you know biological reasons
obviously a matter here to scatter seed
women are here to you know make babies
um women when they're looking at
choosing the father of their children or
their child are looking for men that can
provide and protect for that child and
the most successful guys generally are
the ones that are spoiled for Choice
when it comes to women so I know that it
doesn't sound romantic or sexy or modern
or Progressive but
that's why we're all here today is
because our ancestors chose well the
female ancestors anyway chose successful
men if they chose losers that didn't
have the ability to provide or protect
you know for the children or for the
family you and I wouldn't be talking
today right now as far as the other side
of that equation where women are Beauty
objects
um
that's the reality that's that's why men
talk to women because they're beautiful
right
um they're not talking like I've said
this before and I'm I'm not sure if you
heard it on a video anywhere but it's
like there is no guy ever in history
that has looked at a woman's degree on a
wall framed in Mahogany with little
letters after name that went oh
just look at that degree man that's hot
it doesn't happen otherwise there would
be like porn magazines would have
degrees in them but what's important
magazines like what do men respond to
the feminine figure they respond to
feminine beauty right so
again it's it's not it's not the typical
you know Progressive sort of like
comfortable thing that a lot of people
like to hear but it's the truth right
it's why when you know they tell women
uh hey gal You Know You're Beautiful at
any size I think that's the worst thing
that you can tell when not only is it
unhealthy and you're probably going to
end up with diabetes but you don't look
good telling telling somebody that they
look good completely out of shape is bad
in my view
you disagree with that
um
I mean I do think that I'm definitely
not going to disagree that women are
probably their most beautiful when they
look a certain way or they act a certain
way I mean if women were weren't Beauty
objects and why do they dye their hair
why do they wear makeup why do they put
eyelash extensions on why do they wear
high heels why do they wear push-up bras
right because they know that men are as
well I mean I don't know many of the
same degree I don't men don't go on and
put on like push-up pectoral uh pieces
or anything like that but no they get
implants and you live in LA San Diego I
mean implants fillers Botox anti-aging
hair look I know that there's some guy
that are some guys out there that that
follow that new trend but it's more
Uncommon than it is common all women
will put on makeup almost all women
let's say almost all women in their
youth will put on makeup and nice
outfits when they go out especially if
they're going out for the night you know
with their girlfriends because they know
that their beauty objects and for them
to compete amongst other women they have
to look good
I think a lot of women even if a man had
money would reject him if he were not
physically attracted to them
women would reject him if yeah
absolutely yeah of course see see the
bar for a man is the the expectation out
of men is a lot higher than it is for
the expectation out of women men
prioritize availability essentially it's
as simple as that is she available when
I text her does she respond to me right
if I ask around a date does she show up
like men will prioritize availability
but women it's like you know it moves
all over the place right there's times
in their lives where they prioritize
success and money there's times in their
lives where that doesn't matter he's got
tattoos and a motorcycle and he's just
got thrown out of prison that guy's good
tonight right
it varies it varies but generally
speaking the way that it works is that
men are success objects and women are
Beauty objects
yeah and I appreciate you listening to
my disagreements even though my camera's
off so I hope um Hey listen I I actually
prefer having conversations with people
that disagree because it it leads to
other conversations it leads to other
ideas one of the so let me ask you this
question because where I would like to
take it then is what is a better
solution so if I'm wrong what is your
solution to it
exactly and I think that was my main
issue is sometimes well I haven't gone
too deeply into your videos and I know
to get money from views you have to have
a lot of views and viral videos are
polarizing and part of me wonders you
know is this a strategy for you to make
money and like but yeah just putting out
content that's a little bit more
uplifting to both genders I think and
just looking for Solutions like what are
people in committed happy relationships
doing correctly and how well I do talk
about that too but yeah most people
don't hear those conversations because
they because they don't trend as well
exactly so I totally get what you're
saying because but I have had those
conversations like I've said many many
times like the most successful long-term
relationships that I know with married
couples these are people that I know
intimately well are couples that that
run their lives where they have blue
jobs and pig jobs where the man take
care of the masculine roles in a
household and the women take care of the
feminine roles in a household so they
complement each other's lives right I've
said that many many times but that never
gets the views you know what gets the
views oh she doesn't care about your
struggles she hangs out at the winner at
the finish line and bangs a winner right
like that that will get the views but I
don't control that I just say the words
and then people watch what they want to
watch
yeah even though there's tons of super
loyal women out there who hang with guys
like from the beginning when they're
nothing yeah there's loads of super
white women out there that will stick
through through thick and thin
absolutely true but there's conditions
to that too right like one of the things
that I've noticed with that condition is
whenever I have that conversation with
somebody that's counseling and they're
like but hang on a second Rich I've seen
women bend over backwards and jump
through hoops and and flames and all
sorts of stuff to to do whatever they
can to protect and preserve the marriage
okay then the next thing that I am
curious about then because I know that
women are hypergamous and they always
look for better so are men but men
aren't hypergamous they are they want
the
they want women
emotionally intelligent High empathy
nurturing but that's not the definition
of hypergamy the definition is seeking
somebody of Greater socioeconomic status
in yourself it's it's like it just has
to do essentially with status which
which ties into money and influence and
you know
um being being that that guy that just
starts to get it so you know whatever
women say oh but men are hypergamous too
they're not men just prioritize Beauty
men prioritize availability and you know
a woman when they text them or they
message them that you know they get
together so
we're different and that's what I try to
emphasize whenever I talk to people
whenever they try to challenge me is
like we are totally different and that's
okay and we can complement each other in
a nice way where we can be productive
can we use the term dating up I think
both people want to date up well
definition that is women date up but men
don't usually date up they try I mean
there's a um his ex and she was like a
high-powered ivy league lawyer and he
thought she's brilliant this is this is
how men usually date through time like
if a woman dates a guy with a bus pass
and they break up the next guy has to
have a car and then they break up the
next guy has to have a nicer car instead
of having a Chevy he's got to have a
Japanese car then the next guy's got to
have a German car instead of a Japanese
car sort of thing right so women don't
usually go back financially they don't
like to lower themselves to a standard
that they might have dealt with five or
ten years ago if they've achieved a
higher quality guy or a more top tier
sort of guy men on the other hand they
don't usually go back sexually this is
actually from stand-up comedy right like
it's like you know women prioritize
different things from men right and
that's okay it's it's totally fine and I
put that out there so guys understand be
competent do something with yourself
it's it's not enough to come home from a
nine to five job after you've punched a
clock make 35 000 a year sit in your
mom's basement play video games smoke
weed and then hope a 10 out of 10 is
gonna you know come banging down your
door to want to go out with you right
that's why I tell guys to do the damn
work and on the flip side of the coin I
tell women you know be feminine
compliment his life you know don't be a
boss girl don't be difficult you know be
more agreeable be kind be sweet right
yeah
you can't disagree with that Sarah come
on no I I think being sweet is great I
get my way a lot when I'm sweet so
of course you figured it out right yeah
yeah
when you go out do you put on makeup
sometimes yeah
when you go out with your friends to a
club or a restaurant or something do you
get dressed up you do your hair
yeah of course
that's what I'm talking about because
you know that your value is tied into
your beauty
yeah it is a fine line when you're
trying to attract a partner is like how
sexy do I look like how much effort do I
put in because I know that's what they
want but then it's also like but then
that's I'm also trying to have values
and morals and not be too revealing and
not be too you know it's good too what
do you want you know sometimes men it's
so confusing I'm like what do you want
so you don't want the in the slot
and someone who's like you know
promoting themselves and then if I dress
like a nun no one looks at me so I'm
like well what do you want guys guys
have X-ray vision Sarah we can figure
out what you look like just by looking
at you don't have to show us all of your
skin you just have to wear clothes that
fit you nicely
it's the women that show all the skin
that end up in situations that are you
know problematic it's you know they get
judged you know I think that actually
and you tell me if I'm wrong here but I
actually think that women chain
women more than men slut-shaped women
experience that
you don't see women judging other women
pretty harshly
I so I can only speak from my experience
I have like a circle of women I'm
friends with and we don't do that to
each other but I'm not like out I'm not
like out there I don't have a public
internet career you know I'm right I'm
not a social media person so I'm I can't
really speak for everyone I can just
speak for my own experiences okay yeah
yeah is there anything else that you had
a solution to or anything else you
wanted to talk to Before I Let You Go
I mean yeah I think just differentiating
you know
value of the human versus value in a
sexual relationship I think they're just
very different and like well yeah I mean
like again as difficult as it as it is
to hear that men value women based on
their beauty and their purity
um men need to also hear that women
value men based on their competency and
their success
um I would imagine that you wouldn't
want anything to do with a broke dummy
you know on a long-term basis right like
can I give a dating story about that
okay that's true sure so I was at a bar
nightclub restaurant in LA with the
friends
this guy at our table next to us
first thing I noticed he was tall he was
in shape he was gorgeous maybe 40 years
old little older than I go for
super cute
he ordered ten thousand dollar champagne
thousand dollar stake and he invited us
over he had a huge stack of cash and I
was like what are you guys doing after
this he said we're going to a strip club
and I was like oh is this something you
do a lot and he goes yeah
got my number texted me the next day I
literally never responded to that
because that's disgusting to me but you
gave him your phone number I did yeah
why did you give him your phone number
if that's disgusting then
I thought he I thought he was cute he
was really good looking he had like a
really cute face right he was tall and
he was in shape yeah he was my tank
physically yeah okay so physically he
was your type he found him attractive
yeah because he's a success object right
yeah well you knew the steak was a
thousand bucks right like you knew the
bottle of champagne was ten thousand you
know whatever it happened to be yeah the
stacks of cash is odd to me because most
guys that I know the strip club yeah it
was weird I mean like most guys that I
know they don't walk around carrying fat
stacks of cash right it was super
strange I asked him what he did for work
and they all apparently the whole group
worked together and they were very
covered in tattoos I was like what do
you guys do for work it was very sketchy
it wasn't but it wasn't sketch enough
for you to give him your personal phone
number right I didn't like him you would
have given him a fake number or you
would have said hey follow me on
Instagram or something like that but you
gave him your phone number to your cell
phone
right so you so you kind of
inadvertently proved my point
yeah but I didn't follow up with him you
know because but women always reserve
the right to change their mind later
right that's another thing that I tell
guys all the time so even though you get
the number it doesn't necessarily mean
you're gonna get the date
sometimes she likes you in that moment
or she thinks you're good in that moment
but has second thoughts about it later
right yeah someone who's class like I
don't want some guy going to strip clubs
that's disgusting
right but you still gave him your phone
number even though he told you he was
going to a strip club
yeah you see the irony here right
right so like this is this is the
confusion that a lot of guys have with
women is is they don't really you know
behave in a consistent way with what
they say like I don't like guys that go
to strip clubs but then you go and give
them the phone number anyway right like
when the behavior trumps the words then
I tell guys believe the behavior right
like there was a genuine interest at
that time when you gave him the phone
numbers just you you know you rethought
that maybe you had a couple drinks that
night maybe you were feeling good you're
with your girls this might have been
interesting okay you know you know we'll
do the number swap sort of thing and
then you know sobriety settled in you
said I don't want to hang out with this
guy because yeah the red flag I was like
sober and I was like you know what
that's a red flag so it didn't matter if
he had money or whatever like wasn't
what I'm looking for in a relationship
so yeah but you still gave him the phone
number
why is that relevant I give my phone
number out all the time why why would
you give out something as private as
your cell phone number to a guy that
you're not genuinely interested in
I think I was interested and I was
you were interested and you knew he was
going to strip club anyway but you still
gave them the phone number you see what
I'm saying right like you had a genuine
interest in him it's just it was
fleeting in that moment which is why you
know you you rescinded it
yeah right so look I know that a lot of
the stuff that I say is not always
popular with women but a lot of the
stuff that I say is factual and it you
know just is what it is like I I just
have a way with picking up on these
things right like gotcha
I mean I don't nothing happened I gave
him my phone number like we didn't see
anything happen we didn't see anything
happen nothing happened so what I'm
saying is if you are if you are a woman
that is concerned about your Public
Image you are concerned about not
exposing too much skin you are concerned
with how you hold yourself out to the
public then you should also be more
Discerning in who you give your phone
number to
there's some weird mofos out there right
and you can do a lot with somebody's
phone number
right there's ways to find out where
they live where they Bank where they
work there's some weirdos out there
right
um so I would not recommend giving your
phone number to a guy that might be a
little shady
I know it was just it was the whole
thing about women don't care if men are
promiscuous or they go to sex clubs or
whatever yeah we do like I don't know a
single stable woman who wants a guy
who's just super promiscuous and they
think strip clubs are fun and yeah so
yeah so the whole promiscuity
conversation
um
your your concern for different reasons
than men are concerned like men are men
are more concerned with a woman's past
whereas a woman is more concerned with a
man's future she might have some
interest in his past like if he's been
with a thousand guys and she might say
okay well maybe he has children out
there that I don't know about or maybe
he has a STD which is problematic
obviously so they look at it from that
perspective right but when men look at a
woman and they judge her because of her
past and they say that's disgusting
because she shared her body with 50 men
then it's a legitimate concern right
um the issue of paternity is usually
what drives the disgusted men because
women have a hundred percent assurance
that a child if they are pregnant is 100
theirs but men on the other hand they
don't have any assurance that the child
is theirs unless they know that she's
been exclusive to him so the more men
that she's been with the greater the
discuss that he finds in it right so
again like you can be discussed with a
man's promiscuity but it's generally for
different reasons
I mean if I found out a guy slept with a
certain number of people
probably wouldn't want to sleep with him
or have any type of relationship with
him it's pretty disgusting so you say
that but what but what women choose is
top shelf men that are successful and
their sexual past isn't as important as
their financial future
that's that's just how women choose men
whereas men when they're choosing women
top shelf men anyway when they're
choosing women they're more concerned
with their with their past because they
know that women don't usually share
their pot of gold with men right
I know it's uncomfortable to hear Sarah
but
no but it just
and they're promiscuous and they're gold
diggers oh wait women want status and
success and it's like you say two
completely opposite things I'm saying
the exact same thing right now as I'm
talking to you as I have many times
before covering the same topic it's just
people have selective hearing and if
they if they see this bald guy with a
fantastic beard and he says something
they don't like they automatically
assume everything else that comes out of
his mouth is mischievous and wrong and
offside it's the beard Sarah if you if
you follow my content and and you dive a
little bit deeper in the rabbit hole not
just the surface stuff but if you dive a
little bit
you'll actually find that a lot of the
stuff that I say makes sense and is
actually Pro relationship is actually
Pro men and women
all right you have yourself a good night
thank you all right take care bye-bye I
really hope you guys enjoyed that clip
if you want to watch the full length
podcast you can find that over here that
clips from if you're new to the channel
make sure you hit subscribe over here
and pin down below in the top comment
you'll find a bunch of useful links to
my website my supplement line books and
a bunch of other stuff have an amazing
day peace out